nouveau numéro de votre rendez vous
consacré à la présidentielle en france
france 2022 l'heure du choix désormais
donc tous les soirs du lundi au vendredi
à 20h10 heure de paris avec vous ashwin
verdien bonsoir bonsoir claire et j - 4
avant le premier tour oui et à ce stade
clair un électeur sur trois on sait
qu'on de s'abstenir d'autres ont
l'intention de se déplacer dans leurs
bureaux de vote mais pour jeter un
bulletin blanc dans l'urne autre moyen
d'exprimer sa désaffection envers le
monde politique un vote qui toutefois
n'est pas reconnu en france pour info
lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle en 2017 il y avait eu
plus de 3 millions de bulletins blancs
soit huit et demi pour cent des votants
un record face à ce constat plusieurs
candidats parmi lesquels jean lassalle
propose la reconnaissance donc de ce
vote dans leur programme cette question
et tout le reste de la petite politique
dans le récap de florent rodo et fabrice
p o
c'est l'histoire d'un insoumis
démultipliée
c'est désormais sa signature jean luc
mélenchon et simultanément aux quatre
coins de la france douze villes vingt
mille personnes réunies l'occasion
d'envoyer un message aux électeurs de
marine le pen elle qui selon les
sondages lui barrent toujours la route
du second tour
écoutez vous au les fâcher qu'elle pas
facho à la fin où ça vous même cette
histoire de porte d'essayer porter cette
femme au pouvoir
on y trouve et vous quoi que ce soit
dans ce qu'elle dit ou ce qu'elle fait
qu'ils ne soient pas entièrement teinté
d'une sorte de mépris
de classe du mépris emmanuel macron en a
t'il pour france 2 une chose est sûre la
chaîne publique grincent des dents après
une énième bouderie du président
candidat favorable qui plus est à une
suppression de la redevance j'avais une
question à vous poser d'abord ça va si
vous avez des nouvelles de macron parce
que on pensait qu'il ne lui a pas fallu
longtemps pour créer le buzz
l'anticapitaliste philippe poutou ne
devrait pas passer ses vacances avec
eric zemmour est de 1200 de parole avant
d'accueillir eric zemmour qui se prépare
en coulisses et qui va prendre la suite
vous allez du fasciste raciste accusé
d'agression sexuelle
sourire en coin du candidat de
reconquête cible de choix de ses rivaux
comme jean luc mélenchon pique signée
marine le pen on a deux candidats que
son hémiplégie qu il y en a un qui ne
parlent que de protection sociale et
l'autre qui ne parlent que de protection
civilisationnel et mois précisément je
suis la candidate de toutes les
protections le casse du siècle
ce ne devrait pas être ce dimanche pour
lui jean lassalle a une envie redonner
le pouvoir au peuple
la meilleure manière de le faire c'est
de comptabiliser complètement et de
tenir compte absolument du vote blanc
ce qui fait que dimanche prochain compte
tenu de ce que je vois l de ce que
j'entends dans la campagne
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
et puis ce rebondissement dans la ferme
à qinze est on appris qu'aujourd'hui
mais le parquet national financiers a
ouvert une enquête préliminaire le 31
mars pour blanchiment aggravé de fraude
fiscale à l'encontre du cabinet de
conseil eric zemmour fabien roussel ou
nicolas dupont aignan salue cette
décision cette affaire ne cesse de
prendre de l'ampleur depuis la
publication par le sénat d'un rapport
sur le recours croissant à des cabinets
de conseil privé par l'état et sur leur
influence sur les politiques publiques
et notre coup d'oeil quotidien aux
sondages maintenant et jour après jour
l'écart se resserre entre le président
sortant et la candidate du rassemblement
national selon ipsos oprah steria
emmanuel macron est crédité toujours de
27% des intentions de vote 22% pour
marine le pen qui gagne donc un point et
demi par rapport à hier jean luc
mélenchon gagne un demi point à 17% eric
zemmour lui est en baisse d'un point et
demi à huit et demi pour cent et
toujours 8 pour valérie et creysse du
côté des petits candidats maintenant
fabien roussel est à trois et demi
pourcent jean lassalle à deux et demi et
nicolas dupont aignan à 2% nicolas
dupont aignan qui par ailleurs tient son
grand meeting ce soir dans le 15e
arrondissement de paris quai de grenelle
où l'on retrouve tout de suite notre
envoyé spécial clovis casali bonsoir
clovis quel est l'état d'esprit des
militants sur place
le candidat de dangou de vous la france
est juste derrière moi il en train de
prononcer les derniers mots de son
discours nicolas dupont aignan
particulièrement offensif ce soir en
particulier contre emmanuel macron
entendu la foule scander d'ailleurs
macron en prison et du moins y en
déclaré qu'il faut nettoyer l'elysée ils
ont tué des français ils n'ont pas
soignée et tout ça pour l'appât du gain
et pour des conflits d'intérêts vous
l'aurez compris les grands laboratoires
pharmaceutiques comme pfizer dont le
viseur de nicolas dupont aignan le
candidat de debout la france qui a aussi
parlé de fric site fréq si c'est bien
sûr aussi le rêve de son bras droit un
ancien bras droit de marine le pen effet
florian philippot plan union philippot
qui a déclaré que comme nicolas dupont
aignan il pense que les djihadistes
devraient être envoyés sur les îles de
kerguelen au beau milieu de l'océan
indien et pourquoi pas et y envoyer
macro aussi c'est ce qu'a déclaré
florian philippot alors nicolas dupont
aignan souhaite le fric si qu'il
souhaite reprendre l'argent donné aux
institutions européennes pour les
reverser pour retraités c'est ce qu'il a
déclaré alors nicolas dupont aignan vous
pouvez entendre là la marseillaise
derrière moi
la foule
non
l'aurez compris beaucoup de drapeaux
français et la foule qui chantent la
marseillaise et surchauffée ce soir
c'est le dernier un meeting de la
campagne pour nicolas dupont aignan le
candidat de debout la france tout à
l'heure nous avons parlé avec ses
militants pour essayer de comprendre un
peu qu'est-ce qu'il j'aime chez ce
candidat pourquoi ils préfèrent nicolas
dupont aignan par exemple à marine le
pen
eric zemmour marine le pen avec qui il
avait conclu une alliance en 2017 d'où
mon post où tu d'écouter quelques
réactions de partisans de debout la
france
à
candidat le plus pur qui puisse exister
que c'est le candidat qui a le meilleur
programme
je suis pas un homme qui n'a pas de
dette que c'est un homme humain qui aime
la france qui aime les français il est
dans la vie comme une trame politique
regard des programmes de madame le pen
programme de du poignon n'y a pas de
similitude
pour le balzac sinal qu'est ce qu'elle
fera on n'en sait rien un peu plus
sortir de l'europe
il voit annulé pour daubon tout ce qui
est pas ce fax finale et par la suite
les passes écolo économique
écologique et climatique parce que
bientôt on pourra même pas aller à 500
mètres de chez soi
merci beaucoup clovis pour vos
précisions depuis le xvème
arrondissement de paris merci aussi à
xavier martin et qui vous accompagnent
on va maintenant parler d'un thème qui a
été totalement négligé pendant cette
campagne c'est celui du réchauffement
climatique
oui ce thème n'a vraiment pas réussi à
s'imposer pourtant il ya urgence absolue
comme nous l'a encore rappelé le dernier
rapport du giec le groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat rapport donc publié lundi dernier
son constat est alarmant une nouvelle
fois il nous reste moins de 3 ans pour
inverser la courbe des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre et espérer limiter le
réchauffement à un degré et demi en 2050
c'est et je vous le rappelle l'objectif
de l'accord de paris de 2015 on en parle
ce soit avec notre spécialiste
environnement marina berges bonsoir
marina bonsoir l'écologie dont qui n'est
pas du tout au coeur de cette campagne
présidentielle voilà et à quoi on le
ressent et bien regarder le score de
yannick jadot avec ses intentions de
vote qui sont à 6 petits pourcents qui
plafonne alors que pourtant on le sait
les thématiques portées par les
écologistes est bien sont de plus en
plus présente dans la société française
en théorie les français sont tous un peu
d'accord qu'il va falloir lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique et bien ça
ne se voit pas du tout dans le score de
yannick jadot à 6% alors comment ça se
fait eh bien il faut dire que dans cette
campagne on parle beaucoup de plusieurs
choses on part de tout sauf d'écologie
on parle de pouvoir d'achat on parle
évidemment de la guerre en ukraine de la
sécurité énergétique des thèmes régalien
et beaucoup disent que yannick jadot
peine à incarner cela donc c'est un
agenda médiatique qui est fort peu
favorable aux écologistes et puis il
faut le dire sa campagne à lui elle
s'appuie sur la sympathie la proximité
yannick jadot et souriant et facile
d'accès alors qu'en ce moment en pleine
guerre en ukraine et bien les français
ils ont besoin de quoi ils veulent quoi
ils veulent une stature de chef de chef
d'état assez éloignée il faut dire de
l'image car yannick jadot en ce moment
il le résume lui même yannick jadot à
nos confrères du monde je dois encore
lever des doutes sur la capacité des
écologistes à gouverner la france je
trouve que c'est assez bien résumé puis
un dernier élément qui ne faut pas
oublier c'est la présence de jean luc
mélenchon qui est le candidat qui monte
jean luc mélenchon qui est très assis
sur les politiques écologiques il a il a
beaucoup de deux verres dans son
programme et ça c'est depuis longtemps
ça date pas d'hier donc très clairement
jean luc mélenchon aussi il prend
quelques petits points à yannick jadot
et dans le détail ça donne quoi son
programme à yannick jadot alors on va
regarder ensemble avec quelques mesures
phares on a évidemment cette proposition
clé 100 % d'énergie renouvelable ça
c'est pas étonnant avec un maximum
d'éoliennes 3000 éolienne terrestre
avant 2027 240 kilomètres carrés de
panneaux solaires et puis évidemment un
la sortie du nucléaire avec fermer les
réacteurs qui ne sont plus en état deux
cent mille emplois créés aussi dans la
rénovation énergétique la fin des
voitures thermiques d'ici 2030
l'interdiction aussi de certains vols en
avion ce qui lui semble le plus
déraisonnable un paris lille par exemple
ou un paris-lyon diviser par deux les
engrais et les pesticides 2000 d'ici
2027 vous vous en souvenez ça faisait
aussi partie de la campagne des manuels
macro est bien là yannick jadot propose
d'interdire le glyphosate de verrouiller
ce dossier et aussi les néonicotinoïdes
tueur d'abeilles et puis évidemment des
propositions pour lutter contre la
pollution de l'air qui s'aggrave d'année
en année en france tout ça avec de gros
moyens financiers
à la clé il vient pas les mains vides
yannick jadot alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que par rapport à ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure quand
on regarde toutes ces thématiques la
plupart des français en réalité ils sont
assez d'accord avec ce que propose
yannick jadot avec un petit et pourtant
ça se ressent pas dans les sondages il
ya quand même un petit bémol qui est
cette sortie du nucléaire qui n'est
plébiscité que par 30 % de français
alors il ya une certitude tout même avec
tout cela avec ce programme dont je
viens de vous parler c'est que yannick
jadot attention avec jean luc mélenchon
et le candidat regarder qui se rapproche
le plus des objectifs de l'accord de
paris alors on n'a aucun candidat un qui
est très proche tout ça parce que
certains la plupart en réalité des
programmes ne contiennent pas assez de
détails pour savoir comment on va faire
pour la faire cette pause cette
transition énergétique mais regardez les
deux qui sont les plus proches et bien
c'est bien yannick jadot évidemment sans
surprise et jean luc mélenchon ça c'est
une étude qui a été faite par un think
tank qui s'appelle le chiffre project
avec france info pas de doute yannick
jadot il est bien dans le vert mais ça
ne suffira sans doute pas à atteindre le
deuxième tour merci beaucoup marina pour
cet éclairage donc sur la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique dans les
programmes des candidats et donc
précisément sur celui de yannick jadot
suite à présent de notre série de
portraits il est l'un des deux candidats
trotskistes de cette présidentielle le
leader du nouveau parti anticapitaliste
philippe poutou détonne par son franc
parler et ses idées radicales c'est la
troisième fois qu'il se présente et
malgré ses scores toujours dérisoire il
profite à chaque fois du scrutin
présidentiel pour se faire le porte-voix
de toutes les luttes anticapitalistes
donc écologiste féministe antiraciste
son portrait est signée fadil bayat
dans certains rêvent d'un destin
présidentiel philippe poutou lui assume
la fonction suprême il n'en veut pas
pourtant depuis 2012 il est le visage du
nouveau parti anticapitaliste il prend
la relève du célèbre facteur olivier
besancenot
candidat
c'est philippe avec son vécu
[Applaudissements]
le succès n'est pas au rendez vous avec
un score de 1 15% à la présidentielle le
candidat anticapitaliste appelle du bout
des lèvres à voter françois hollande
nous le disons qu'avant
s'ils pensaient en rester là en 2017 il
est à nouveau investie par le npa
désormais connue du grand public
philippe poutou prend goût à l'exercice
et sort les griffes notamment face à
françois fillon et marine le pen
cantonales est convoqué par la police ne
vous voyez par exemple on a pas
d'immunité ouvrière désolé on y va voilà
vous avez une chance le système
pour vous mais le candidat reste
cantonné à 1% des suffrages après
l'élection philippe poutou s'illustre
par son combat contre la fermeture de
l'usiné ford à blanquefort où il est
salarié malgré le soutien du ministre de
l'économie ford refuse les offres de
reprise et met la clé sous la porte en
2019 philippe poutou est licencié en
2020 première victoire électorale
l'ouvrier au chômage fait ses premiers
pas en tant qu élue au conseil municipal
de bordeaux nous on pense effectivement
que notre véritable force c'est pas
juste les trois élus parce qu'à trois
élus on n'est pas fous on sait qu'on
pèse pas plus lourd que trois autres
élus d'un autre parti mais par contre
c'est le lien qu'on va faire avec tout
le monde associatif syndicalistes avec
même y compris des salariés de la ville
et puis tout simplement et le mouvement
social une responsabilité nouvelle qui
ne l'empêchent pas cette année d'être
candidat pour la troisième fois à
l'élection présidentielle
philippe poutou pincer parrainage in
extremis et il est prêt à en découdre
boudé par certains médias le candidat
l'assurent il ira jusqu'au bout pour
faire exister ses idées son rêve mettre
fin au capitalisme
[Applaudissements]
demain
et on en reparle avec notre reporter
karina chahbour qui couvrent pour nous
cette campagne présidentielle bonsoir
karina philippe poutou un candidat qui
détonne c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est vraiment le candidat du franc
parler pour lui la langue de bois mais
ce n'est pas son truc il aime les
saillies il est réputé pour une certaine
forme d'ironie pour une répartie
toujours avec des formules bien senties
il a une certaine gouaille qui lui vient
sûrement de son passé d'ouvrier et de
syndicalistes dans le secteur automobile
il a d'ailleurs reçu ces dernières
heures le soutien du chanteur populaire
renault mais son projet il est
clairement radical vous l'avez déjà un
peu abordé son ennemi c'est clairement
le capitalisme les politiques qu'il juge
ultra libérale et antisociales son idéal
c'est la révolution et s'inspirant cela
du bolchévique léon trotski il défend à
la fois les ouvriers et tout un tas de
cause traditionnellement classé à gauche
que ce soit l'antiracisme l'antifascisme
vous l'avez dit mais également le
féminisme ou encore l'écologie d'un
point de vue politique lui il veut
abroger la vème république il veut en
finir avec la fonction de président de
la présidence de la république qui selon
lui considère trop de pouvoirs il veut
aussi fermé le sénat une assemblée de
notables élus par des notables il veut
instaurer un système de proportionnelle
intégrale et il veut aussi accorder le
droit de vote à toutes les élections
pour tous les résidents étrangers il
veut d'ailleurs régulariser l'ensemble
des sans-papiers une prône ce qu'il
appelle la décolonisation des
territoires d'outre-mer et de la corse
au nom du droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux mêmes et qu'en est il de ces
propositions pour l'économie karina là
vous savez un slogan c'est nos vies plus
que leurs profits un slogan qui
d'ailleurs a été détournée volée par le
président candidat à la défense lors de
son meeting le week-end dernier c'est
c'est jamie ces mesures il souhaite en
finir avec des productions des
productions qu'ils jugent inutiles comme
par exemple dans l'armement dans la
publicité il veut réduire fortement le
transport aérien après qu'il veut
saucier 10 et une économie autour de
grands centres de pôle public et de
renforcer les services publics il ya
d'ailleurs prévu de créer un million de
postes de fonctionnaires supplémentaires
s'il était élu il veut interdire tout
simplement les licenciements réduire le
temps de travail à 32 heures
hebdomadaires
il veut instaurer une sixième semaine de
congés payés la retraite à 60 ans est
instruite le smig relever le smic à 1800
euros net par mois par mois oui
absolument bon petit certaine façon de
travailler moins pour gagner plus il
veut également réquisitionner les
logements vides et sur l'énergie il
prône la fermeture de toutes les
centrales nucléaires d'ici à 2030 de et
parvenir à 100 % ne renouvelables en
2050 mais sans expliquer ce qui se
passera entre ces deux dates
il veut également exproprier le géant
pétrolier total entend on l'a dit c'est
sa troisième campagne
présidentielle les deux fois précédentes
il n'avait guère atteint plus de 1,2
environ 15% mais pour lui l'essentiel
est ailleurs puisque c'est effectivement
plus une campagne de témoignage où il
s'agit de profiter de cette tribune de
ces quelques semaines pour faire parler
de lui il a d'ailleurs déjà laissé
entendre qu'une fois cet épisode passé
et bien ils chercheraient du travail et
poursuivra la lutte merci beaucoup car
henin pour ce point donc sur la
personnalité le programme de philippe
poutou et c'est tout pour ce soir le
merci beaucoup et sereine verdien vous
retrouve demain soir à 20h10 à l'aso lui
ment 2 paris c'est la fin donc de france
2022 l'heure du choix à demain h rennes
a retrouvé cette émission bien sûr sur
notre site internet
www.francebillet.com et sur les réseaux
sociaux rester avec nous paraît direct
continue on se retrouve dans quelques
instants pour un nouveau journal